[Music]
asheville north carolina glenn is with
us hey glenn how are you
you're doing great dave thanks for
taking my call i really really
appreciate all you do you too sir how
can we help our family's been very
blessed in that
our children are registered with uh
through my wife are part of a native
american tribe
and so they pay money into uh
i guess it's kind of a trust fund for
them that they can't access till they're
18 and then they disperse it for a few
years after that
we have seven children and they're all
registered so my approximations of the
oldest is 16 right now and my estimates
are that when they turn 18 it'll be in
the neighborhood of about 250 thousand
dollars before each beginning
so
each correct yeah
so so my question for you was
i mean i have some ideas but i wanted
your opinion on what kind of things
should we be doing in the home to teach
them about money now as well as make
sure that once they get it they don't
squander it because we know a lot of
other people that are in the same boat
and
you know they buy cars and end up in a
ditch in a few years and you know it's
it can be pretty it's pretty sad i know
it's not 10 million dollars but it's to
us it's pretty substantial amount oh it
is substantial it is and this this
happens a lot and we've worked with a
lot of tribal
situations because the money has turned
out to not be a blessing
because it's caused people as you said
to fall into addiction
to fall into a lack of a work ethic
because they think they've got it made
without working because they're on the
tribal dole
and
it's
it's had a socio-economic effect that i
don't think anybody really saw it was an
unintended consequence across the board
right certainly certain individuals have
used it to be a blessing and others it's
it's really damaged their life which is
really sad and so we've seen that so you
guys are this is probably what cherokee
correct correct yeah okay all right cool
yeah been there been to that harass yeah
so um
the uh yeah sure i mean i was born in
maryville so cherokee north carolina
just up over the hill from us sorry yeah
so i've been around this my whole life
but it's just become extremely
profitable because the casinos in the
last few decades for a lot of the tribes
so anyway all that to say
um
it's a little bit like growing up in a
wealthy family only the family didn't
earn the money
right and so you have to guard your kids
about against the dangers of wealth
which are sloth
addiction and misbehavior sloth meaning
laziness
okay
and so we had to teach the ramsey kids
as an example growing up that they had
that they're entitled to nothing
don't talk to me about entitled
uh i you know a ramsey kid get jacked up
growing up if they start acting entitled
and especially if they start
acting like my dad's on the radio so i
get to do so and so i really jack you up
you start playing the dave card rachel
can tell you stories from her childhood
that left scars
and so because it's just because i was
not going to have our kids turn out as a
reality show because we built wealth and
i wanted quite the opposite the wealth
needs to be a blessing
and the money is not the problem the
problem is how you react to it and so
what you have to start teaching your
kids as early as possible is that this
is
this is not you hit the tribal lottery
this is you have a tremendous
responsibility
with great blessing comes great
responsibility
and i want you instead of feeling like
you had like you scored a touchdown
in the super bowl and like you did
something fancy because you hadn't done
nothing
you just hit the dna lottery that was it
that's all you've done
you're entitled to nothing here so
instead you need to take this money and
see it as a responsibility
to your family
you know your own future family to
yourself to your community and so wealth
is a it is a responsibility and i want
you to feel the weight of that we did
that through a spiritual lens saying we
don't own it god owns it we're managing
it for him so we have the responsibility
to be faithful
to be trustworthy worthy of trust in
this and so there's going to be a lot of
dad speeches in your house
if you're wise
and you know teach them to work
teach them to act like this money's not
there if they act like the money's not
there they'll be just fine and that
money then can be a blessing
and they can hold it with an open hand
with a generous hand
they can hold it with a hand towards the
future
um all of those kinds of things and and
so but it can be done you can teach a
kid in a rich family work ethic you can
teach them integrity you can teach them
character uh you can teach them delayed
pleasure uh you can teach them the
generosity
um but but where this all falls down is
when it becomes very all about me all
about me all about me that's the
entitled arrogant mentality that that
sometimes the truth in a sense it's like
a trust fund baby right
right yeah so uh smart money smart kids
is the book that rachel and i did that
was the number one bestseller that
addresses how to raise kids and teach
them how to handle money we talk about
this kind of stuff in there i'll send
you a copy of it uh george what do you
want to add to that you've watched
rachel and daniel and denise around this
place yeah there's zero entitlement and
all work ethic and what i've seen glenn
is that money is going to make them more
of whoever they are and so whatever they
are at age 18 well that's how they're
going to handle that money when they get
that 250k so what i want you to do is
raise them in the best way you can walk
them through the principles of smart
money smart kids have them go through
financial peace university maybe as a
family and then you can start to go hey
what are your goals this money can then
flow through that framework that you've
worked so hard to build to where they go
cool we're going to cash flow school
we're not going to take out any debt
we're going to get ourselves a car we're
going to have a down payment for the
house we're going to have a fully funded
emergency fund and what that's going to
do is catapult them into their adult
life while their peers are hanging
behind with all these student loans and
car payments they are able to have a
paid for house at 24. yeah here's the
deal they can be college educated with
zero debt and be millionaires by 28 with
the numbers you gave me
yeah and that's kind of what i told them
i said you can you can work because you
want to not because you have to very a
very young age the rest of your life and
you can learn the real value of money
which is not what it does for me but
what it does for others
yeah it's the most valuable thing a kid
can ever learn and sometimes it takes us
kids till we're 50 to learn that one
and your kids don't have that option
because if they wait till 50 this is
going to screw up their lives
yeah and uh it's a scary scary thing i'm
glad you brought it up i've not answered
that question here on the air i've
answered it behind closed doors with a
lot of discussions with tribal leaders
because they're facing this uh because
it's created in some cases not every
case but there's too many times it's
created kind of a welfare state
mentality rather than the blessing that
it should have been yeah uh because the
the tribes are you know they're
dispersing the money to the tribe that's
the money they're making in the gambling
industry which is a
boatload of money a boatload of money
and so i'm glad the young man young
ladies are being blessed it's a good
thing
let's just make sure it is that they
understand they're blessed so that they
can be
a blessing